Hi zusammen! Heute gibt's Snickers Cookies, meine ultra-leckeren Snickers Cookies!
Und das Ganze nach dem LES-Prinzip!
Hamza, hast du gut aufgepasst?
(H: Was?)
Weißt du nicht, was das LES-Prinzip ist?!
(H: Was ist das?)
Lecker, einfach und schnell!
L, E, S! *Grillenzirpen*
Okay, los geht's! *lacht* Wir machen..
(H: Cringe Alarm!)
So, wir rühren jetzt alles zusammen, ganz einfach
ohne Küchenmaschine heute mal. Könnt ihr natürlich auch benutzen aber ich hab' gedacht ich zeig's euch mal so.
Ich hab hier Butter geschmolzen. In der Mikrowelle bei geringer Wattzahl für ca. 360W 1min.
Wenn ihr höher geht Leute dann platzt die Butter auch, das wollt ihr nicht!
Wie oft ist mir das passiert? Hamza, du bist mein Zeuge!
(H: Sehr oft!)
Wie oft, oh mein Gott!
Die Butter ist jetzt abgekühlt. Das ist super super wichtig,
jetzt kommt nämlich brauner Zucker dazu.
Und ich schreib' euch alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben in die...?
(H: Infobox!)
Infobox!
So, das verrühre ich jetzt miteinander
und danach kommt schon das Ei mit dazu.
So, als Nächstes Mehl und Backpulver dazu sieben.
Und im ersten Moment sieht's so aus, als wäre das echt viel Mehl aber das ist richtig so. Das ist so eine Masse,
ich kann die eher zeigen als beschreiben. Die glänzt so ein bisschen, die ist dick.
Und dadurch, dass ich jetzt ein Ei Größe M benutzt habe, muss ich jetzt auch keine Milch mehr hinzufügen, kleiner Tipp von mir!
Habt ihr ein Ei Größe S, dann so einen Schluck Milch noch dazugeben aber das werdet ihr merken.
Und dadurch, dass es jetzt Snicker Cookies sind - Hamza, was sind die 3 typischen Eigenschaften eines Snickers?
(H: Erdnuss)
Ja!
(H: Karamell)
*flüstert* Schoko!
(H: Ach Schokolade!)
Erdnuss, Karamell und Schokolade, genau!
Und daher natürlich kommen Erdnüsse rein. Bitte nehmt da gesalzene, nicht die ungesalzenen nehmen!
Und wenn ihr doch ungesalzene nehmt, dann fügt auf jeden Fall richtig schön Salz dazu oder Meersalz.
Meine sind schon gesalzen. Dann habe ich hier - das sind die Erdnüsse -
dann habe ich hier so Sahnekaramell-Bonbons und die backfesten Schokoladen-Chunks.
Und die Karamellen hier, die werde ich jetzt noch klein hacken und dann hebe ich da alles nochmal unter.
So! Schon fertig der Teig, das ging super schnell!
Und jetzt werde ich einen Teigportionierer nehmen,
dann könnt ihr euch nämlich sicher sein, dass alle Cookies zeitgleich fertig werden weil ihr halt immer die gleiche Menge habt.
Und ich gebe auch nur 6 Cookies auf ein Blech
weil die gehen nach dem Backen noch auf. Ihr müsst jetzt auch nicht reindrücken oder so,
die gehen ganz von alleine noch - die werden noch flach sage ich mal.
Der Ofen ist auch schon vorgeheizt auf 190° C Ober- und Unterhitze, die Backzeit verrate ich euch gleich aber noch.
Und ich gebe oben drüber auch noch von unseren 3 Toppings was damit's später auch hübsch aussieht.
Leute ich sag's euch ganz ehrlich: 7min, maximal 8!
Bloß nicht länger! Ihr müsst euch vorstellen: Der Ofen ist ja vorgeheizt, das ist ganz wichtig
und auf dem Blech bräunen sie noch so ein bisschen nach - zumindest von unten - weil das Blech ja noch dementsprechend heiß ist.
Und - ich korrigiere!
(H: Und, und, und!)
Und und und! Gebt nur 4 Cookies auf ein Blech
weil es kann schon - schaut mal hier. Es kann schon passieren, dass die aneinander kleben.
Und dann hab' ich jetzt einen richtig coolen TIpp für euch: Ihr nehmt euch jetzt einfach eine Schüssel
könnt ihr so auseinanderfriemeln...und dann macht ihr folgenden Move:
So!
(H: Karate Kid?)
Karate Kid, Ta-da! Sieht hübsch aus, ne?
Das mach ich jetzt mit dem auch noch. Guck mal, jetzt sieht der noch nicht so schön aus.
(H: Ah, okay!)
Kurz zum Vergleich und auch als wertvoller Tipp:
Der Cookie war 10min drin und jetzt würdet ihr vielleicht meinen: "Ja, der ist schön goldbraun!"
aber der ist schon zu dunkel. Also der wäre mir schon zu knusprig.
Ich finde Cookies müssen schön weich sein. Und wundert euch nicht:
wenn ihr die aus dem Ofen holt, sind sie noch so, dass sie euch zerbrechen wenn ihr die anheben würdet.
Lasst die kurz auf dem Blech abkühlen und dann werden sie nach dem Abkühlen auch fest.
Ich nehme immer meine schicke Hebepalette und dann hebe ich das ganz vorsichtig an.
Ihr könnt's auch ganz vorsichtig anheben und dann auf ein Abkühlgitter tun falls ihr Angst habt,
dass es euch unten auch zu knusprig wird. Der Rand darf nur ganz leicht goldbraun sein
und dann sind sie fertig. Und ich fordere jetzt den Hamza hier auf, dass er rumkommt und mit mir den Taste Test macht.
Guck dir diese Schönheit an!
(H: Sehr schön wie du das so präsentierst!)
Weil die so hübsch sind!
So wir probieren mal und wir sind natürlich immer super super ehrlich.
Wenn uns was nicht schmeckt, dann sagen wir das auch. Nein, sagen wir aber auch wirklich!
(H: M-hm!)
Sollen wir jeder einen oder sollen wir den durchbrechen zusammen?
Machen wir's romantisch?
(K: Ja!)
(H: Nee! *lacht*)
Okay..
(H: Ach Gott, du bist voll enttäuscht!)
Nein, nein alles gut! Passt schon!
(H: Echt?)
Ja..
(H: Nein komm, mach mal zusammen!)
Okay!
(H: Du bist hier die Arme! Komm, komm!)
(H: So?)
Ja! Uuuh!
(H: Ich will die Schokolade!
Okay, nimm du das Schokostück!
(H: Okay! Nein iss, ich glaub da ist Schokolade.)
Okay, wir probieren jetzt mal. Zur Konsistenz: die sind schon sehr fudgy,
erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Subway Cookies..
(H: Subway!)
(H: Wir haben's fast gleichzeitig gesagt!)
Jaaa!
(H:Wir sind äh.. seelenverwandt!)
Wir sind seelenverwandt!
Also die Konsistenz ist geil! Die ist wirklich geil, die ist nicht trocken oder so.
(H: Hab's schon gegessen!)
Ich probier mal!
Boah! Mmmmh!
Also ich find' die sogar noch geiler als Subway. Also die Subway Cookies schmecken ja..
Ja, die schmecken halt ultra frisch und selbstgebacken!
(H:Ja die schmecken einfach..auch mit dem Karamell und der Schokolade..)
Ja?
(H: Da schmeckt man schon richtig Snickers raus finde ich!
Auf jeden Fall!
(H: Obwohl hier kein Snickers drin ist!)
Ich hätte ja auch Snickers klein schneiden und reinmachen können
(H: Meine ich ja!)
aber ich fand's irgendwie so cooler und das Tolle ist wirklich bei diesen Cookies: Ihr habt halt diese Salznote,
die Schokonote, dieses süß-salzige, ich lieb's! Und es ist auch nicht zu salzig, also es ist gerade richtig!
Es schmeckt extrem nach Snickers. Wenn man jetzt keinen Snickers erwischt - also keine Erdnuss, Schoko, Karamell zusammen - dann nicht wirklich.
(H: Aber wenn man diese 3 Komponenten zusammen erwischt, dann schmeckt man richtig Snickers raus.)
Auf jeden Fall! Auf jeden Fall.
Boah, richtig lecker!
(H: Du hättest auf jeden Fall bei meinem Stück ein paar mehr reintun können. Erdnüsse, Schokolade und Karamell.
Bin ich auch - ja, sehe ich auch so! Also geizt nicht mit der Schokolade!
(H: Bei dem z.B. nicht!)
(H: Guck mal, der ist voll beladen!)
Ja!
Also geizt auf jeden Fall nicht! Wisst ihr was? Ich ändere euch auch die Mengenangaben so, dass ihr genug Schokolade habt,
dass ihr genug Karamell und genug Erdnüsse habt.
Finde ich richtig geil das Rezept, gefällt mir richtig gut!
Ich bin ganz ehrlich: das ist ein spontanes Rezept gewesen. Ich hab' mir einfach überlegt: Snickers Cookies!
Ich wollte erstmal eine Snickers Torte machen, jetzt ist es schon so spät und die Snickers Torte machen wir dann übermorgen!
(H: M-hm!)
Und dann kommt die auch ganz bald online.
(H: Ich ess' den Rest auf!)
Ja hau ruhig rein. Ich gönn' mir gleich auch noch einen
und dann wünsche ich euch ganz viel Spaß beim Nachbacken! Ich freu' mich ´über eure Fotos,
markiert mich auf Instagram. Und dann würde ich mal sagen sehen wir uns bei meinem nächsten Video!
*beide* Tschüüüss!
Eure Kiki!
Und der Hamza!
(H: Schmeckt mega lecker! *flüstert*: Alles meins!)
Ich bin glücklich! *lacht*
Ich bin glücklich!
(H: Warum bist du glücklich weil du gegessen hast?)
Essen macht glücklich und Süßes sowieso!